currency is your new project it's a
Kickstarter campaign that has I think at
this point six days left what is it
about and how did you find out about the
subject matter well I think I think
Christopher you can okay so currency is
a environmental thriller and it takes
place in Cambodia and it really explores
the illegal fishing trade and also the
corruption that kind of enables it to
keep going as most people are familiar
with Cambodia had a really horrible
genocide you know 30 or 40 years ago and
in our movie we didn't want to really
touch on that much but it really does
sort of set the climate for what's going
on there ever since that happened you
know there the genocide you know wiped
out a whole culture of academia and
almost a whole generation of people so
now what you see is the the people who
can it came into power and filled that
vacuum the power vacuum have been
running a country for a long time and
the country is become really corrupt and
kind of run on this informal economy and
it's also going undergoing rapid
development now because the development
had been so depressed for so long and
those two things together created this
environment where lots of resource
exploitation has been happening and the
proceeds of that have not go into the
country but to individual members of the
government and you know sort of rich
people in the community who have
relationships with the government so in
how that played out in the oceans is
that their Cambodia is traditionally an
agricultural economy and on the
coastline that means fishing and a lot
of subsistence and small-scale fishing
but over the last ten years or so
there's been an increase in trawling
activity and I can go to a trawling
because a minute and also a lot of
bigger boats coming in from neighboring
countries like Thailand and Vietnam have
started competing with the local
fishermen on a more industrial scale
which you know then in turn forces some
of the local fishermen to increase their
ways of fishing oftentimes through
really destructive fishing techniques
that are a lot in most other countries
and even are outlawed in Cambodia those
laws to start enforced so it's become
this sort of arms race of destructive
and illegal fishing practices in this
part of the ocean and in order to get
away with it they basically pay off
those corrupt local officials who pocket
the money and then choose not to enforce
the laws that is the background of the
issue but what our film follows in
particular is an investigative
journalist who has been writing about
these issues for the last three or four
years in Cambodia
or actually four or five years at this
point and then another our other main
character is conservationist who's
trying to create a Marine Fisheries
protected area and in that process
patrols it and kind of confronts a lot
of these fishermen and which often turns
into serious confrontations and
conflicts and sometimes sometimes are
violent sometimes are dangerous for you
know him and his crew and they cause a
lot of I guess turmoil for his project
would you say it yeah so those are the
two main characters but we also follow
some some local people on there are two
and actually four young Cambodian
University students who are actually as
far as we're aware some of the first in
their country particularly in their age
that are actively pursuing careers in
marine conservation and we follow the
two female students in their group and
they were staying with Paul in the
island to do their thesis project and
they're doing it on creating a small
artificial reef and monitoring that
which what they'll learn there Paul and
his crew are scaling up now that they've
been approved for their larger marine
fisheries protected area they're going
to use that same process to demarcate
the boundaries of the area and kind of
put in these
snads for the trolley nuts but they also
create habitat firm for local wildlife
so in which one of you came on for
Stephanie did you hear about the project
first or was it Christopher well I've
been working in Cambodia for probably
gosh the past three or four years I
started interning out there I had an
internship in human rights and I was
working at an NGO that was monitoring
the Khmer Rouge tribunal and I kept
going back there to work on another
documentary of mine and I became friends
with Christopher a couple years later
and Christopher learned about this guy
this vigilante environmental activist
Paul Ferber who was fighting illegal
fishing in the Gulf of Thailand in
Cambodia and he told me about it and we
just decided that we both had to make a
documentary about this work and
everything that was happening there yeah
I think it was a natural pairing because
you know stephanie has got a lot of
great producing skills which lacks
organizational skills and Olympic but
also yes she I've never been to Asia at
all and she spent a lot of time over
there so as soon as I heard about him
like the I know that I know now know the
perfect person to approach about working
on this together so if it she's been
dispensable I don't feel like don't know
if I could have or would have done
without her so well yeah and the film
wouldn't be what it is without
Christopher it's been his filmmaking has
been absolutely superb and very
impressive it's you know over the past
year that we've been working on this
it's you know it's a lot of running done
out there and Cambodia is difficult to
shoot in there's you know it's usually
90 percent humidity and a 100 degrees
and especially on the island that Paul
lives on and but things have really
evolved naturally from us working
together to working with Paul and you
know meeting and Matt and having him be
part of our story too and all of the
other Cambodian characters that we've
been working with it's it's been a
really natural evolution yeah the
Kickstarter video is
so we'll put a link underneath this
video for people to look at so was Paul
sorry the first person that you
contacted or how did that transpire yeah
I think I think he reached out to Paul
yeah I yeah I guess when I heard about
Paul I found his I went to the he has an
organization that he started called
Marine Conservation Cambodia and I went
to their website and sent an email I
think to the general information email
and we actually heard back from this
woman Charlie who is a photographer and
was you know basically found out about
Paul and kind of just was volunteering
her time to help coordinate because on
their small island they don't actually
released at the time didn't have good or
any really cellphone or internet access
so Charlie would respond to their
communications and then she eventually
set up a call with that we had with Paul
late one night yeah like a 15 hour time
difference I think yes and they were you
know I think that we got him at the
right time they were having trying to
figure out how to do some fundraising
and I think that they thought that you
know having having some more exposure in
the media would help them with that so
we definitely actually had already
planned a trip out there three weeks
from that conversation and that was
right around the same time that I was
thinking would be good to go and so we
ended up I ended up buying a ticket cos
she already had one and then we went
together and we worked for about ten
days on this project and then maybe
three or four on some other projects
that Stephanie had so yeah I'm just
curious what what type of an email are
you sending to someone because you know
that this is like this could make or
break whether they respond to you is
this a long email short email how are
you wording it yeah so accesses of
really in documentaries accesses
probably 25% of what makes a successful
project maybe even as high as 30 or 40
you know luckily after doing tiny I
think that being able to say that I had
a film on Netflix and it's funny that
Netflix is alike yeah the catch word
these days but yeah saying that I had a
film on Netflix oh it has opened up a
lot of doors in that regard and people
take you more seriously so that's like
really fortunate that that I could do
that so basically my email would look
like
a little bit about my background you
know how we found out about them and
then and just like let's talk more not
really you know because we also don't
really know when we reach out to people
what we want to do necessarily with them
because you you kind of hear what might
be a good story but you don't really
know until you kind of get there and you
see what's going on in fact when we
started this we also thought it was
going to be a short film and then once
we got there we met Matt who became our
primary character really and we realized
that the context of everything going on
their enhanced Paul story but like there
were other stories and it was all part
of a larger story of what's happening in
the region and that's when we thought we
can make a feature so we you know we we
just you got to keep things fluid and
open in the early days and so we you
know we kind of just have a very broad
idea when we contact people that we want
to do something we think but we're not
sure what yeah and I think something
important too when reaching out to
possible characters in a documentary if
you're not sure is just making sure that
they feel safe in the email and making
sure that you've like researched like
it's really important to give the
impression that you've researched them
and that you know what you're talking
about
you know because just telling them that
you know you want to reach out to them
or that you want to talk to them about a
film it usually isn't enough especially
you know if people have been kind of
burned by media or you know haven't
always been portrayed in the best light
or are unsure of what kind of context
something is going to be shown in so
it's really important to make the people
feel safe so that they can at least have
an initial conversation with you and not
to correct you but I would say that even
rather than make him feel like you've
done the research it's actually you know
doing the reviewing which is right now
but yeah yeah I mean you have to do the
research you have to you have to know
what you're talking about in the email
you know as brief it as it is in the
beginning and you have to you know just
just show your stuff a little bit yeah
yeah I also think that this is probably
a larger question but like you know
actually approaching with good
intentions
people can tell that you know from your
first phone call and I think it's
important to do particularly
documentaries I think it's particularly
due for the right reasons and and being
honest and straightforward and
transparent and you know that all that
bleeds into your whole relationship with
your subject which is like I mean we
could have a whole conversation about
that and how tricky it can be to to
maintain a good working relationship I
mean not even working relationship just
a relationship with with the subjects of
your film because it's fraught with all
sorts of potential you know pitfalls and
things like that
you